Lo que tenemos aquí son dos modelos de partículas
de dos mezclas diferentes. Podemos nombrar al
modelo de la izquierda como mezcla número
1, mientras que llamaremos mezcla número 2
al modelo de la derecha. Ahora bien, con base
en ellos, quiero que pauses este video y con
sólo mirar el modelo de partículas de cada una de
estas mezclas me digas si son mezclas homogéneas
o heterogéneas. Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos.
Las mezclas heterogéneas son aquellas que no son
consistentes en toda la mezcla, las propiedades no
son las mismas en toda la mezcla. Entonces podemos
ver que el modelo de partículas número 1 es una
mezcla de dos tipos de partículas diferentes;
sin embargo, todas las partículas anaranjadas
están concentradas en la parte inferior,
mientras que las partículas moradas están todas
concentradas en la parte superior, por lo tanto,
las propiedades en la parte de arriba serán
diferentes que las que tendremos abajo. Entonces,
si viéramos esto en algún tipo de evaluación,
podemos responder con seguridad que esta es
una mezcla heterogénea. Ahora, ¿qué hay
de la mezcla de la derecha? Una vez más
tenemos una mezcla de dos tipos de partículas
diferentes: las anaranjadas y las moradas,
pero podemos ver que éstas se mezclan de manera
bastante consistente en todas partes, incluso,
aunque estamos viendo un modelo de partículas por
aquí, las anaranjadas se distribuyen uniformemente
entre las moradas, o podemos decir que las
moradas se distribuyen uniformemente entre las
anaranjadas. Así que si vemos esto en algún tipo
de evaluación, podemos estar seguros de responder
que esta es una mezcla homogénea. Bueno, ya sé
lo que algunos de ustedes están pensando: "Sal,
digamos que justo aquí tenemos una especie
de mezcla líquida homogénea". Ahora bien,
con un movimiento aleatorio estas cosas podrían
deslizarse una sobre la otra y con el tiempo verse
un poco menos uniformes. Entonces es interesante
pensar en qué escala estamos observando esto. Es
posible que tengamos el caso de algo que a
un nivel macro parece homogéneo, pero que,
debido al azar, no se vea tan homogéneo en un
nivel de partículas. Pero cuando veas algún
modelo de partículas en una evaluación y
te pidan que compares cosas como éstas,
es bastante seguro suponer que cuando nos muestran
algo muy consistente entonces se trata de una
mezcla homogénea, y cuando nos muestran algo que
es muy irregular, no consistente o distribuido de
una forma desigual, entonces se trata de una
mezcla heterogénea a un nivel de partículas.